brought to you by Far Cry primal rise
above extinction in stores February 23rd
hey guys today it is the 15th of
February my name is Jess M here's what
matters in gaming today look at League
developers psyonix recently spoke to
Larry Major Nelson herb about their
eSports strategy which they think it's
going to be very good for the game
psionics exec Jeremy Dunham explained
that there are already undisclosed
things in the works that will help them
expand into eSports adding we never went
in with the intention of specifically
being a successful eSport we knew we had
the chops for it that we had the
groundwork but it's all about the
community and players and whether they
dig in you worthy of being one he
emphasized the strength of the rocket
League community saying that there
continues to be a lot of twitch players
broadcasting the game even eight months
after launch rocket League is expanding
their soccer car reach to Xbox one On
February 17 Square Enix has revealed
that hitman go definitive edition will
be coming to PlayStation Vita ps4 and PC
on February 23 the term based puzzles
spin-off of the sandbox assassination
game will feature upgraded visuals and
all post-launch content that was
released for the original mobile version
the PlayStation version supports
crossfire which means if you grab it on
one platform it will also unlock for
free on the other the game will also
cross save across those platforms if you
manage to get through it without using
hints PlayStation players can look
forward to a platinum trophy while PC
players will get all the good stuff
steam provides including trading cards
emoji cloud saves and achievements no
pricing details have been confirmed
finally it looks like nekked who might
be on its way that's according to a
LinkedIn profile which is proving to be
a notoriously useful way to find out
what's on the gaming horizon given the
recent reveal of watchdogs to a resume
of a 3d animator work
Taiwanese development company xdc
entertainment listed that she had been
working on that too since May of last
year she states that she animated 3d
character motions and cut beans for neck
to on ps4
although the listing has now had the
reference to an ax equal removed it's
worth noting that the mention of knack
to doesn't necessarily mean it's in
development and Sony hasn't confirmed
and you work on it as yet NACA the first
released as a ps4 launch title in 2014
our reviewer gave it a four out of ten
saying without that special something
Mac crumbles just like it's piecemeal
protagonist
let me know down in that comment section
if you would play a sequel to neck and
head to games but we've got news on Call
of Duty sales and the Final Fantasy 8
remix album that is everything I have
for you today let me know what you
thought about today's stories and I will
see you again tomorrow